Hello everyone.
Welcome to toxic dual.
I'm Kevin Valve with the Google team.
And here we are in sunny la at youtube space.
So how awesome is it?
Space and all the guys.
Okay,
so this full productions facility,
we're really,
really excited here because we're doing something brand new that we haven't done
them toxic Google before.
We're doing a youtube three 60 degree live stream.
So we're live right now across the world.
And these two cameras that you see here are 360 degrees.
So for you guys watching online,
what we're going to be doing here today is,
uh,
interviewing the cast to finding dory.
So we're gonna bring him up here in just a second.
So if you guys watching online,
if you're watching on your mobile device,
just take your phone,
just look around and complete 360 degrees.
Then we got some fun stuff here in the back.
You can look around the production facility,
um,
and then four,
if you're on desktop,
just take your mouse,
click the video,
move it around,
and that's it.
So,
all right,
we're going to meet the cast.
Well,
let's bring him out,
ladies and gentlemen,
the cast,
the voice cast and creative team behind Disney.
Pixar is finding dory.
Ready?
Welcome guys.
Hello.
Thanks so much for coming here.
Um,
so,
uh,
finding dory out June 17.
Thank you guys all for being here.
Uh,
Ellen,
welcome.
Uh,
so,
uh,
this is a movie completely about your character Dory,
and you've been characters as well,
right?
Uh,
thank you.
and uh,
but so York,
yeah,
go ahead.
I've just found that out.
I'm dory
and so,
but you were huge cheerleader for this film for years on your,
uh,
on your shows.
Thank God I had a show.
We would not be sitting here had I not had a talk show.
Talk about
yeah.
To intimidation.
Yeah.
He finally called and said uncle,
he's like a,
all right,
we'll do it.
We'll do it.
It was,
they said I was just kidding.
Yeah.
Where was like,
no,
I'm not interested.
No,
it was a,
it was started as is.
I seriously wanted a sequel.
I was like,
they make sequels for every other successful film.
We want an academy award for crying out loud.
So where's the sequel?
And then it just got to be a joke and then I just gave up and I was just,
well,
I'm just going to keep going because it's funny.
But uh,
and then it worked out
and then 13 years later,
so Andrea,
you brought this back 13 years later.
So when did that idea,
besides Ellen pushing?
Yeah,
when you make these movies that you see them so many times.
So I'd seen finding any more about a hundred times before 2003 even finished.
So you just stop watching.
And about eight years later,
it was 2011 they wanted to put it out in three d they put me in a theater and I
watched it like an audience member for the first time in a long time.
And I walked out so worried about dory.
I was just like,
she's gonna Forget Marlon Nimo.
She won't know how to get back.
And I don't know where she's from.
And I think that,
yeah,
she's got abandonment issues that I know about as a writer.
So it like suddenly it,
it's just all,
it just all started to bubble up after that.
It's,
it's unbelievable.
And it's,
it's wonderful thing.
I've seen it.
It's,
it's
otherwise,
as long as you're here.
Yeah.
Make the third one before we die.
Oh,
okay.
Oh
well I'm,
I want to get to you actually about your character to Marlin Marlin's back.
Um,
and we have the new voice of,
uh,
Nimmo birth up there.
Hayden Hayden,
say hello to everyone.
Hayden Hayden's actually 30
ladies were really good.
Nine year old,
like you guys didn't know yet.
And so l a Alberta,
your character Marlin is back obviously.
And it's interesting cause it was really,
really great to see you.
Now I have a completely different dynamic with your son Nemo.
And now Marlon is much more protected over Dory.
Who wants to go find your family?
So can you talk a little bit about where Merryn is at the stage and,
well,
I know he doesn't agree,
but I thought that Marlin was in love with Dory.
I mean it,
that I just figured that,
you know,
whatever it makes the seats were for,
y'all heard Marlin's lonely and,
and,
uh,
you hadn't found anyone else and she's lovely and you know,
why not?
But,
uh,
I think we have the next seat.
I was just gonna say there's your third.
Um,
but you know,
we,
it was great.
I Hayden's terrific.
Alexandra Gould,
who played the first one,
he's 42.
I actually was in weeds with him after he was neem.
Roy played his grandfather and weeds.
So that was sort of interesting talking about pot with Nemo
know,
but,
uh,
Hayden's wonderful and,
you know,
like a modern,
divorced family.
Here's a new kid.
There we go.
It's going great.
Uh,
so ty and Katelyn,
you guys play new characters in the film.
So we have,
uh,
Bailey,
which is your character tigh and then designate.
So tell us about your characters.
We're buddies.
Yeah.
Uh,
basically,
uh,
Bailey and destiny are,
two people,
the Dorian lists to help her find her folks.
People.
There are two people dressed in whale and the whale shark costumes.
It's like an abstract kind of a thing we do.
Is did you dress in
wheel costumes when you recorded this?
Didn't need to do or the only live back moving.
It was exhausting.
It has been so hot.
It's really hot.
Yeah.
You're Bailey's a big Beluga whale and a destiny is a giant whale shark and
they're kind of a brother,
sister relationship and then get on each other's nerves,
but they're very sweet and they ended up,
uh,
trying to help dory out.
Great.
And we have an exclusive clip we're going to play here in just a few minutes
with your two characters.
So what,
bring that up here in a little bit.
Um,
but Alan,
so you know,
you're returning to the character of Dory.
Um,
it's a really,
really emotional story about her trying to find her parents.
So,
um,
you know,
when you first read the script,
was there anything that you were able to bring to the scripts or tell Andrew,
I'm looking for this and the character.
I want to go this direction.
Um,
no.
I,
I mean this guy is a genius.
This,
I,
I'm not going to tell him how to write a script.
Um,
I mean,
when I was in the room I changed a lot,
but I,
yeah,
no,
but you know,
that's what's great about it.
The script is fantastic.
The script is what it is,
but it's,
it's open and free enough that you do,
you know,
50 takes and,
and you can then you just do whatever you want to do and he chooses,
they choose whatever it turns out to be the best one.
So it's always the first,
but you know,
it's four years writing this thing.
I mean,
so we're doing,
but there was over 10 drafts of this story done over that time and they know
that what we're working with them and you also adapt to the actors once their
cast.
So you're,
you're,
you know,
I'm learning just as much from them and we're rewriting to play to their
strengths so that it's like hopefully comfortable shoes almost.
And they,
and,
and you just,
it becomes a little symbiotic at a point.
And Eugene,
you play Charlie.
Yes,
that's correct.
Other of Dory.
Yeah.
So what can you tell us about Charlie and,
oh,
well it was a,
it was exciting to play a,
a dad who has a child not doing strange things with pies.
Uh,
that was a big plus.
Okay.
That was a,
that was like your first question and the,
yeah,
write that out.
Yes.
Does dory eat baked goods?
No.
Uh,
no.
It was kind of a,
it was a very charming,
well,
I was just,
I was honored to be included in this thing,
no question about that.
And playing a dad,
uh,
you know,
have a child who is,
kind of memory impaired,
so to speak.
So there,
you know,
it's,
it's kind of a very funny,
very amusing and,
and there's something very heartfelt about playing,
um,
you know,
uh,
Dad,
um,
where,
whose child is off somewhere.
You don't know what happened and you know,
will they ever be able to,
you know,
how will they function because the,
the,
she has no memory,
a short term memory.
So,
you know,
um,
it's,
uh,
it was interesting and complicated and fun and exciting.
I mean that's a real powerful part too.
And he didn't know,
I'll get right back to you.
But Andrew and Lindsey,
when you're creating this story about you,
you,
you use a very much of a comedic effect in,
um,
in finding nemo where you have Doerries character with short term memory loss,
but it's a real disability in life and you really,
really hit it home in this film.
So was that,
I mean cause she's really struggling with that.
You see in the beginning of the film you see it throughout.
So was that a point that you really wanted to drive home and yeah.
Well she's the main character.
Once you have a main care cause it has to be more depth to them and they,
and you sadly are sort of forced into a bit of a straight man role when you were
in the main character role.
The thing that it was always great about stories that I always knew that tragic
side of her that was always,
uh,
I always knew her optimism and her care giving and her candy spirit was somewhat
her armor to protect herself from the sense of loss she had.
So it was just sort of flipping that on this film.
It was,
it was great too,
because I remember the day that you,
there was this the scene where I had to explain what short term memory loss was
and how to explain it.
And that was one of the Times that I could just go and talk about what,
what to,
how to explain it to s someone's hurt.
I mean,
it was funny and heartbreaking at the same time at the same time.
And I think that's kind of what the movie really leans into on this one that
it's like it's charming and,
and that is dory.
And we kind of,
you know,
we were always trying to walk that line between the charm that it was dory and
that is Ellen.
And then also the,
you know,
the kind of tragedy really of it.
And,
and making sure that we never lean too,
too far one way or the other.
So that we felt like it was being really true to this character.
No,
it was a delicate balance.
I mean that's what it was like in the beginning,
the movie,
you first,
your initial reaction is to laugh.
It's like,
oh,
that's dory.
And then it starts getting deeper and you're like,
Oh God,
I don't like,
it's,
it's really,
really intense.
So,
uh,
Hayden,
the new voice and Nimo,
um,
pretty exciting from my hometown of Chicago.
So welcome here to California.
Um,
so was it like to be an email?
uh,
it's very fun being able to pretend that I'm just a cute little fishing.
I'm not.
Yes.
And I'm not just me.
I actually get to pretend that I'm something that's a very good idea and very
fun to do.
Yeah,
no,
it's your,
we were wonderful in it.
It's crazy.
Cause I was,
when I was watching it and I actually didn't realize the first one,
the trailer is that they got a new voice.
I was like,
well of course it is 13 years later.
And you,
you pull your sound exactly like him.
It's it,
it's great.
He's like the Darren of bewitched,
you know,
like he had to show your folks watch original Darren and it's really tough.
And so a lot of this takes place in,
which is a great thing cause it,
you can find an email,
you see the characters going through open water and oceans and everything and
you have different investments.
But now you're in a marine institute and it's so for you,
you,
Lindsey and Andrew,
when you guys are there,
there's a lot of creative ways of how the characters get around the park.
But what was one of the most complicated scenes as a producer?
Lindsay,
you're just like,
really?
I think
honestly that was the,
it was when Andrew came and was like,
so we've come up with this new character and he's an octopus.
And I said,
I'm sorry,
what?
And he said,
he's an octopus boy.
He's a step to puss.
So you get one less technical.
He is a Hank the octopus.
No doubt is the hardest character I think anybody at Pixar has ever done and
took two years.
I mean,
normally our characters take kind of nine months start to finish and this took
two and a,
he took two and a half years just to build and rig.
Um,
and so that was one where I was like,
really?
Does it have to be an octopus?
Could you maybe not?
Huh?
Maybe turtle.
No,
already have that now the front plastic,
the first shot took six months to anime and we're,
we're never going to get
finished at this rate.
But,
uh,
fortunately ready,
got smarter and faster.
Okay.
Gotcha.
And what environments where some of the most complicated ones,
cause you see them in pipes,
it's in the tanks.
If you watch finding Nemo,
you'll notice that there was like only three shots I think,
where we allowed Andrew to put the camera in the corner of the tank of the
dentist office.
And it's because of the reflection refraction talking to people at Google and
youtube.
So I feel like I'm in a people you understand that.
Um,
so it's,
and it's really hard.
I mean we,
we intentionally didn't do that because the,
the computer couldn't do it and we had to direct it and fake it,
all the lighting.
And so the new renderer are actually allowed us to do much,
much more in.
And we took both do it everywhere.
We basically,
he did it everywhere.
I'm like,
yes,
every possible container has blast and reflection in itself.
Gotcha.
Um,
and so,
you know,
are there any,
what I loved was,
you know,
I remember watching,
I'm a huge Pixar fan animation fan and I love watching in the first one some of
the making of it and you kind of tacked onto this um,
flashback thing and the first finding an email where you want to do flashbacks
and kind of tell the story through that.
And it's a great plot device that you used here throughout the movie as well.
The kind of tell Doris story.
Was that something you immediately knew that you wanted to do?
Work that is going to 11th hour idea that saved our butts on this movie.
We came up with it last fall,
but a lot of people don't know.
Nima didn't come together till the last six or eight months.
Um,
like all the pieces were that we just didn't happen.
It didn't have them lines.
Right.
And so I feel like this movie's in good hands in a weird way because it did the
same pattern.
Um,
but yeah,
the first movie,
all that tragedy you see at the beginning of finding Nima,
all that loss was actually flashbacks that were doled out and it just didn't
work.
You didn't sympathize with Marlin,
but once we saw his tragedy at the front,
we moved at all the fountains and suddenly all the lines we'd always had played
fine.
Everybody empathized with them.
Um,
and then this was the reverse.
We have too much information at the front and then when we doled it out and made
it memories that dory or has and is triggered,
she goes,
it became like the inverse of the first movie in it.
And it just felt right.
It was Jason.
Yeah.
You can take that into your own life.
Start every conversation with your saddest story.
It.
Okay.
And so now we're going to Q,
a,
uh,
exclusive clip here from finding dory.
So let's clear it up.
Okay.
Can you please keep it down over there?
My head hurts was that
he was brought in with a head injury.
I know you're talking about me.
Destinee we can't use this.
Echolocation but I've overheard the doctor's time writing every word you're
saying about me.
What's echolocation?
Well,
Bailey's head is supposed to put out a call and the echo helps him find objects
far away.
Oh,
put.
Apparently he's still healing.
No,
I know you're talking about me.
I really can't echo like,
hey,
I have this conversation again.
I just hit my head very hard out there and see how it's going in his head is
supposed to be big.
You're a Beluga.
Yeah.
So ty and Katelyn,
those are your guys' characters.
Uh,
Bailey and destiny.
Did you guys record it all together to get some of the dynamic and Improv?
And we did.
That was,
that was fun.
We got to do two or three together because you know,
mostly you just in there by yourself with these guys,
right.
Again,
well we got to do a couple together and it was really fun cause it's,
we're actors,
we're used to working with these spies by the way,
are amazing.
They're too smart for us though.
It's much.
I'm always looked on people.
Yeah.
She was looking for an idiot.
That's your phone one.
That's right.
It makes me more comfortable.
It makes me feel smarter.
Um,
yeah,
that was actually,
that was new for me.
I,
I haven't done a ton of animation,
but the chances to go in and be in the room with,
well,
Katelyn in particular who's so funny,
um,
it's all,
you know,
the whole process is so collaborative.
Um,
obviously we're not really tinkering with any of the major writing,
but these guys were just so smart and so much changes as you're doing it.
Um,
the,
when we were able to do it together,
it really felt the freedom to play around a little bit and see what else was
there.
Yeah.
That's great.
So we're going to bring up our,
uh,
one of our youtube topgraders smoothing to ask some questions that he got from
our social media.
Again,
social media handles.
So let's bring him up.
Hi,
check,
check.
How's it going guys?
All right.
So we asked a lot of our youtube subscribers and the youtube people's out there
some questions and a lot of them were coming toward you.
Andrew.
They want to know how you go about selecting
thing voices for your movies.
Oh,
well,
you know,
everybody knows the term that the camera loves them.
They're very photogenic.
But I like to say there's a term with a microphone.
Loves them.
They're people that just have voices that you can just hang a character on and
sitting in front of you.
Or five amazing example.
Six,
I'm sorry,
I can't count today.
Six exam.
Was I the one you weren't thinking.
I wasn't thinking a year,
not loving time.
There's five in front of,
you know,
for
one guy who just tried
super hard.
Those are hard working guy.
But it's true.
Like when you want it.
Like I,
I was,
uh,
started out as an animator.
So I really recognize like when you hear a voice that you just can't,
you can't help a project,
a character on,
you can't help it.
Like want to see a acting from out of,
out of,
out of a different character.
It's a [inaudible].
And so you end up with these lists sometimes.
Um,
uh,
Ellen herself as somebody I wasn't thinking of at the time when I was really an
early days of writing on finding Nemo.
And then I heard her off of the television set and boom,
you know,
it's suddenly matched.
I had been a fan of Albert's,
you know,
ever since I can remember watching going to all of his movies and listening to
his comedy albums and sorry,
just waiting for the right role to fall for that.
And then Katelyn,
same thing.
I'd sort of been a fan of her voice and tie and a Hayden I discovered and Eugene
of all these are people that I've just been fans of hearing and I just go,
they would be perfect,
but you're just waiting for the right character that you're coming up with and
hope that somebody else hasn't grabbed them before you do.
What's the other thing too?
On Youtube?
A lot of us are one man production teams and a lot of us do animations so
there's a lot of people are wondering how do we start off anybody that wants to
be involved with animation,
the process just out the gate.
What would you recommend as far as programs for anybody starting out?
Okay.
God,
I don't know.
I mean I'm too old now.
I don't,
I don't know.
I started out with Pencil and paper.
I still use pencil and paper.
I don't know if anybody knows what that is,
but all of the school like stone age stuff.
Yeah.
All I can say is it's so easy.
I mean,
now you can make a movie in your house.
Like,
like I get to steal stuff,
like when I did it,
you know,
to like get them to get movies made and my backyard stuff and,
but so I'd just say like,
do it,
do you grab whatever you can and do it.
Like there's nothing stopping you.
So just do it.
Uh,
I mean this one was popping up a lot.
we can go on to,
all right.
What about other animated Disney films?
If you could be in any of those other animated Disney films,
or what movie would you want to be in?
I am a huge fan of all the Pixar movies and particularly all of Andrew's movies.
I was a huge fan of Wally and all the toys stories,
those are just,
I watched those before I had kids and then I,
my little boys love those movies.
So those are the ones that are always on.
And so when I got the call about this,
I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
I don't care what I'm playing.
But yes,
whenever I'd like to get the candlesticks
go and building on the base.
Nice.
Even the Broadway version?
No.
Matinees
what,
what about you hate in any other movie,
Aladdin,
Lion King,
any of those that you'd want to be in?
Um,
I don't really know if I'd want to be in any other movie besides this one.
Good answer.
Yeah,
you're checking whale.
Buenas Ellen,
what about you?
Uh,
same answer.
I would never,
I'd like,
this is the one I thought Dory was great in finding Nemo.
Um,
joy and inside out would have been fun.
I like joy that,
uh,
I mean I'm very happy being dory.
Eugene.
Anybody?
No,
I,
you know,
the thing of it is really these pictures,
all the picks are animations are so incredibly great that,
and the process is so much fun to do.
I mean,
I don't know if anybody really understands exactly what you do when you're in a
studio,
but it's really quite amazing.
And when you get to work with,
you know,
incredible,
incredibly talented like genius people here,
uh,
where you kind of just give a line and they,
as you're giving the line in the,
in the,
in the scene,
they kind of know they're making changes as they're going,
try it this way,
try it this way.
And it's all happening in milliseconds and it's just like,
it's an incredibly exciting way to work because I've got to act with Diane
Keaton.
So that's probably why he's on a high.
I know my wife isn't here today.
Um,
yeah,
so that was a,
that was good.
That was kind of a fun too.
But yeah,
I I,
you know,
I would say it's just,
it's a really fun way to work doing animated films and when the scripts and the
stories are as,
as exciting as a finding dory,
then you know,
you're,
you consider yourself very lucky.
Okay,
awesome.
That's all the time I have for you guys.
We have some crowd questions later,
but I'm going to toss it back here.
Thanks so much for your time guys.
Thank you.
I see.
Suzy.
So we're gonna take some audience questions.
I think they're going to start lining up here.
Um,
here we go.
Hey,
you hear me?
Yeah,
I kind of want to ask a question if everyone,
but I'm going to focus on dory.
So don't be offended.
It's all good.
You're all cool.
So my question to you is in finding norb Dory,
one of the mantras for me was just keep swimming,
which is I'm a plus size health and fitness motivators.
I help women like me starting,
reengage it.
The s so to me it's about the journey,
bracing the journey.
Just keep moving no matter what happens.
Just keep going.
Well 11 who you are in the body you're in.
So what I be curious to know is what is your life lesson coming out of finding
dory?
Did you have that moment that just keeps living moment that really stood out to
you?
Um,
well,
my life is,
that's,
that's my motto as well.
That was my motto,
I think.
Okay.
It's yours now.
We'll share.
So sorry to steal it from you.
Second lawsuit.
Oh,
I'm aggressive.
Um,
well it was,
it was kind of like my model.
It wasn't completely my motto.
MMM.
Because I think if 51 knows my story,
it is,
I had to just keep swimming.
I,
you,
my life has been
a lot of challenges and a lot of,
uh,
different,
curves and,
uh,
and,
roadblocks.
And so I think that's a great,
you know,
I didn't come up with just kip keep swimming,
but it,
it has turned out to be something that a lot of people can hold onto and use in
their life.
And so I would say just everything I think is,
I'm,
I am so blessed and lucky that that's part of my character that I get to say,
just keeps,
keep swimming for whoever you are and whatever you're going through.
Well,
thank you for that because it's a big life changer.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Hello.
I just wanted to know what your favorite aspect of working on this film has
been,
whether it's recording,
fleshing out the story,
promoting it,
et Cetera,
of anyone you've had,
the big you've had probably the most accused from.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's honestly working with the actors is probably my favorite simply because
they're sitting in front of me.
Um,
no,
it's,
it's actually because it's the one part of this process over four years that's
spontaneous where you're actually doing a lot of give and take in the moment and
you're kind of,
you're in the now and you're just reacting.
And,
uh,
I find that so exciting.
I get very little of it.
We came in animated pictures,
so I'm pretty hungry for it when we do these sessions.
I know they're grueling,
they're long,
these guys stand around for four hours and they're just on the whole time.
So they're basically doing a one person show.
And a lot of them I know,
I've said that,
that it's the most tiring thing they do simply because it,
there's no breaks built into it.
And,
um,
but um,
it's,
it's pretty invigorating.
It's pretty exciting to me.
Okay.
Hello,
I'm Christina cal from the channel back,
girls ball.
Um,
this question is for everyone.
A lot of people in the audience,
including myself,
are content creators here at Youtube.
And I just would like to ask you all what advice you'd like to give us with
building our careers.
Super Lucky.
Yeah.
Weirdly lucky.
Oh,
that's a horrible advice.
Someone asked a question earlier about to Andrew about how do you animate
something and you know,
I would say the answer is the same and that's a story you start with that you
start,
you're a content creator so you don't start with the actors.
You don't start with upset,
you start with a story,
you start with the content.
And if you have a great story,
it can fit a hundred different ways to tell it animation,
it can fit live action.
So you know,
think of great stories,
just stories that you haven't heard.
I say that's a basis to start with.
I would say authenticity.
I think whatever.
I think when you,
if something's happened to you in the same thing that Albert saying,
if you have a story,
you're probably not the only person with that story,
whatever it is.
And sometimes the best stuff comes out of the hardest stuff and the worst stuff
that you've gone through.
So if you've actually experienced something,
I don't think anybody should hide any kind of truth.
So whatever you have witnessed or experienced or gone through,
find a way to express that and find a way to stay.
And I think people read truth and authenticity and I think that's the most
important thing for establishing anything.
And even if you don't have something,
you must have a horrible uncle.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
Hello.
So I know a lot of you have experienced with Improv and just being quick on your
feet and I was wondering how much room there was for improvisation.
It seems like a lot from what you've been saying,
um,
but how that improvisation,
uh,
affects the process and the final product and how it might be different from
other animated films as it was with finding dory.
Well,
I dunno,
it compared to other animated films are,
are different.
Some of the Simpsons that I've done,
the whole thing was Improv'd.
There's always a solid script here.
And the thing about Andrew is that once she gets those words,
if you're willing to keep going,
he'll take every word in the English language out of you.
So you know by the end of the day you've given a lot of choices.
Hopefully there's some choices he didn't think of and then they have to,
the,
the thing I'm most grateful for is I don't have to listen back to these
recording sessions because after 9,000 takes,
I just,
you youtube
every,
every person here,
there's at least one or two lines,
if not more,
that are in the finished movie of things that they came up with on the set that
I would have never written.
So,
but you know,
it's generally an animated films.
I think it's generally welcome because it's at the stage where it's still,
you're not coming into a finished movie where you have to fit the exact words in
a mouth.
So they generally,
if you can do it,
they welcome it.
This is a question for Ellen and Dory.
How did you learn to speak?
Well,
that's very good.
First of all,
mmm.
I was in Hawaii and there was a,
a woman who was staying in the house next to the House that I was renting and
she was doing yoga and like crazy yoga,
like on rocks and um,
and listening to whale sounds like,
I didn't know you could buy that record,
but there's a record that just is whale sounds.
And uh,
and I was listening to it and I just,
it just was like the most,
it was the weirdest thing I'd ever seen in my life.
And I just thought a wave is going to take her out any minute.
And it didn't kind of wanted it to happen because it was just so weird that
she's on her head on a rock.
And,
um,
so anyway,
I just knew what a whale's sounded like.
And so,
uh,
I didn't think I'd ever need to use it in life,
but I did.
I was so scared to ask her this.
I thought this is going to be the thing.
This is going to be the something,
you know,
this isn't gonna be the thing that makes me go,
okay,
I'm done.
I'm not in this movie anymore.
I'm out.
And I'm like,
would you be willing to speak well?
And she told me this whole story right away.
It just went right into it.
Oh,
I can speak whale.
Right.
And I've been waiting.
So that's it.
And it's a,
it's not easy.
I mean,
you did it very well,
but if you have to do it a lot,
yeah,
it's very,
uh,
it's tough on your vocal cords.
You have to kind of,
yeah.
Warmup.
Caitlin had to do it a lot because her care characters,
the reason dory knows how to speak well.
So
yeah,
it did it a lot.
They'd look at me and go,
um,
one last thing.
Okay,
let's just do it.
Give me some tea.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Hello.
My question is where Ellen,
what was the craziest moment that have been onset when recording the movie?
Finding Dory?
Uh,
the craziest moment.
I don't know if there was a crazy moment,
but uh,
yeah,
when you're back you couldn't even stay at your backwards.
I don't even remember that.
We did give it to the secure.
So what happened like
right before you came in?
I still had to do at a four hour sessions with us and we were like,
we're really sorry.
Could you do one more?
That's right.
That's good.
Well it's,
I don't know.
It was crazy.
It was sad.
Sad.
One of the saddest.
Do you want a sad moment are crazy.
Yeah.
I forgot.
And then I literally,
I had to still do it because other version where you got in that horrible
accident.
Yeah,
I remember that time when I was so crazy.
Crazy,
crazy.
Ellen.
Yeah.
Um,
I was gonna say,
uh,
this is just an excuse to complain about it,
um,
that they,
because dory is always either left behind or catching up to people.
So there's a lot of hyperventilating,
like breathing,
really just guys,
you know,
it's that,
or it's like screaming and like a lot of those.
And you think that once,
I just did that,
you could use that throughout the whole film,
right?
Yeah,
but I had to do it all the time.
I had to like and I was just like,
do you,
don't you really have the already,
so there was a lot of that and when you see this film and you should see it many
times,
um,
you,
you will see that I don't do it that often in the film.
And I don't know why he needed this first comment that was like,
that was like Ellen was like,
I really loved it.
Where was all the gasping and waiting like literally that was her first
question.
Where is it?
It's in the toys.
Yeah.
I see.
That's how they get ya.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Hello.
Hi.
Oh,
who came up with the idea for Sia to cover unforgettable.
And how did that all come about?
Oh Gosh,
we know who exactly what we,
you always wanted this song.
I just thought it was always,
I said they've got to have one syllable.
That's the only thing I care about that,
that's just one soul and we don't want to know what she looks like.
Yeah,
no,
but it was the,
the song was always there.
Like you always wanted that song at the end of the movie and you were knew,
we knew it was going to be covered and didn't want the original.
We wanted it.
Robbie Robertson and province said Robert Robbie Williams,
I had actually covered,
um,
beyond the sea on the first movie.
And so I wanted it to feel like that same sort of complimentary modern day
singer plus an old classic and see it was
pretty much on the top of the list.
We were talking to you about it.
Yeah,
I was in a session and they said,
we,
this is the song is going to be unforgettable.
And um,
they said,
we're thinking of Sia and I got my phone out like,
let's see how fast we can make this happen.
I'm right now.
And so I texted her and she's like,
are you kidding me?
Of course I would love to do that.
So it was like that quick.
She just was so excited.
So it turns out when you know islands and generous,
you have to be a friend of Elliot.
And it happened pretty quickly.
I was texting with CEO too.
That's a thing as she was texting with me when she got that text and I was like,
all right,
go,
Ellen needs you.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Uh,
so a couple of things with Allianz too.
So we are,
uh,
Google also partnered with Pixar and Disney to,
basically give you guys a lot of really cool content,
uh,
on the knowledge panel.
If you type in finding dory on Google search,
you'll see over on the right hand side of the knowledge panel was a whole bunch
of stuff that Disney has been doing,
trailers and gifts and a whole bunch of stuff.
So it's been really cool stuff.
So thank you guys so much for providing that.
You guys probably didn't know,
but it's there.
And so now you guys know,
so check that out.
I'm also,
uh,
to celebrate finding dory today being a world oceans day.
Um,
every but everyone's a tuning in,
you know,
just to,
uh,
help our friends of the sea.
So there's a donate button in the,
in the live stream links you'll see there.
Um,
and after this as well,
uh,
to the wildlife conservation society.
Oh,
I hope you just literally had friends at sea.
I was scared.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
to help save rays,
sharks,
and other wildlife and wild places across the globe.
So,
uh,
yeah,
it's a great thing Disney is doing.
So if you guys,
I looked that up and so,
uh,
what we're going to do here is going to be something pretty cool and you guys
are all going to be involved.
You guys ready?
Right?
So we're going to take a show fee.
Okay.
Yeah.
Terrible Pun.
I know.
Um,
uh,
so as soon as it get,
come on up here.
So what we're gonna do is guys in your seats,
just stand up.
Don't crowd the stage.
We're going to take the cancer going to stand right here.
Uh,
so we're wrapping up here
guys.
So finding dory is going to be in theaters June 17th.
Uh,
so just a couple of weeks.
So check it out and thank you guys so much for being here.
Let's,
yeah.